i had the uh nha guy which is uh
basically like the
tv license the television man the
television man yes basically if you have
a television you should be paying
attention
he's the other death reaper yes the
other one i'm acquainted with
came to my door and he was like he
looked at me he just stared at me and
like oh when i opened the door
and i was like
yeah and i was like hmm i saw the nhk
thing in his hand and i'm like
what kind of knife
so explain the nhk guy is like nhk is
like the
the it's like it's not cable it's like
the tv the national
yeah right and basically the nhk guy
comes and like you usually if you own a
tv in your house you have to pay like a
fee
yeah like a license if you use the tv
if you have like a kind of like a tv
connection right yeah if you have a tv
connection
yeah that's the a lot of people just own
a tv because you know they use it for
things like
streaming or like for games like not to
actually watch japanese tv
yeah but the nhk guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't care he's like if you own a
tv
you have to pay the fee yes it's
actually the law apparently
yeah it is the law apparently but like a
lot of people it's also just like a
waste of money to just be like i'm not
going to pay a fee for something i don't
use i actually
can't get the tv because it come you
have to you need it yeah yeah yeah i
don't have the car
right it's like the nhk car yeah i don't
have it yeah i can't and yet they
they're just so persistent to like get
you to pay that fee for something that
you don't even use yeah it's like you
know you have to understand i don't use
the tv
to watch [ __ ] nhk all right like i
i'm a millennial a user for other things
like gaming stream
and streaming you can't run away because
even if you don't
speak japanese they will pull out google
translate
have fun i felt like i had to be careful
mentioning
mentioning them because i was doing a
playthrough of a game and there was this
character that reminded me of the nhk
man
and i just had to keep i had to keep
it's uh
mad father yeah the nhk man
special appearance in doom nah nah it
was a game called mad father and there's
this guy
oh yeah i [ __ ] love that game stream
yeah i did it's a three-part series yeah
it was